welcome to the show that puts you at the
center of the national conversation
talking about the issues that matter to
you the most
tonight
everyone is going to pay more tax as
election slogans go it's not obviously a
winner but that's the warning from
Jeremy Hunt ahead of the Autumn
statement on Thursday the chancellor
also said he'd make eye-wateringly
difficult spending decisions to stop
Britain from going bust
it may be sound economics but what
effect will his decisions have on you
I'm Trevor Phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines this week
Jeremy Hunt will lay out his master plan
for the economy it'll be tough
don't expect him to pull any rabbits out
of any hats though he's already told us
that everyone will have to make
sacrifices but many people are already
struggling unions are preparing for
strikes across the public sector
is a return to austerity unavoidable
as ever our viewers panel from around
the country and around the world will
have their say their tell their stories
I'm here in the studio joining us are
the General Secretary of the university
and college Union Joe Grady
housing campaigneboa
the consumer editor of the financial
times Claire Barrett
an economist Vicky price
the big question tonight
who should bear the brunt of the Autumn
budget
[Applause]
British people know that we're right
they know that when you've maxed out on
One credit card it's not the right thing
to rush off and get another one
austerity is indeed ending we
crisis
pretty
we need a new approach for a new era
families have to make sure that in the
end they don't just max out on their
credit card without having any way of
repaying those debts it's just the same
for countries we're all going to be
paying a bit more tax I'm afraid
[Music]
12 years and what have we got low growth
low productivity and a cost of living
crisis
it is a historic moment one of the worst
economic forecasts this place has ever
produced
that's not going to help anyone if if
interest rates keeps borrowing that's
not going to help anyone food banks are
at Breaking Point as 1.3 million
emergency Parcels that are given out in
just six months
the chancellor is understood to be
targeting tax Rises and spending cuts
worth between 50 and 60 billion pounds
if this plan survived to the other side
of an election I'm a banana
yeah
okay let's begin as we always do with
our viewers panel with the wall and uh
talk to Andy Whitehouse in Derbyshire in
the village of etwall I think uh you are
Andy
it is uh Trevor good evening good
evening good evening who do you think is
going to take the pain here
well if I could just um tell you a
little bit of History if I may
um back in 1997 uh an MP called Edwina
Curry
opt into our back garden and asked if we
were going to vote conservative
we said no and she asked why not
and my late wife then said
we're two working people with two cars
with two jobs a brand new mortgage with
a middle income and we also pay all our
taxes
you look after the rich
you look after the pensioners
and you look after those on benefits
what are you going to do for us
her answer was this
there is a hole for those in the middle
and we need to do something about it
after that she left
now moving fast forward to today nothing
much has changed
so
my question to the panel
is this
should the chancellor carry on
penalizing the working man and woman
or should he look at those who can
afford to pay
and those who shouldn't be Molly coddled
so um
and Andy You're pointed really about the
just about managing as Theresa May would
have called you rather than the very
poor the very rich okay let's go to
another member of our viewers panel and
uh talk to Andy Andy Huff
good evening good evening you're in
nurse I think
like mine is not probably a popular
thing but I think one of the ways to do
this is that everybody everyone in this
country
should be means tested as this is
already done by indirectly by the hmrc
but not effectively working against the
rich
okay so that's a way of focusing uh the
resources on those who need it okay
thank you very much Andrew your question
for our panel is should more people be
means tested Claire Barrett
everybody says they want to help the
most vulnerable is that the way to do it
well the problem with means testing is
do we have the data needed to to do it
and we've seen time and time again with
all of the help schemes that were rolled
out in the pandemic things were made at
Great speeds to try and assess who was
the in in need of the greatest
assistance and there were consistently
large groups of people who were excluded
from the support that was needed it's
very very hard to design systems that
really reward those who need the money
the most and we're seeing that again at
the moment with all of the various
energy help support schemes that the
government has put in place none of them
are perfect the warm home discount which
is the one that they try to reform last
year that's now making payments at the
moment the boundary lines for that have
changed and Charities are up in arms
because people who receive disability
living allowance and personal
Independence payments so now now
excluded from that help whereas disabled
people face some of the highest costs to
heat their homes and run life-saving
equipment so it's very easy to say we
can just means test everyone and it will
be fine in practice it's very difficult
the other thing which I'm sure we'll
talk about later on is where does that
leave the state pension because of
course the state pension is a universal
benefit it's paid to everybody whether
they're on the breadline whether they're
a millionaire well we're going to come
to that I think that that will be coming
the means testing
Vicky price you once had the
responsibility for
advising government on the economic
policy what do you think about this
issue about how you focus resources
because Universal benefits of one kind
or another are enormously expensive
well the substitute and we saw that
happening during the coverage period
when of course Universal Credit was
increased but we did see that it did
make a difference for people
and what we saw also when it was finally
withdrawn this extra 20 pounds a week
benefit that was given that there was a
huge outcry so it was I think going to
the people who needed it most and it was
very widely used and it did make a big
difference but of course what we're
talking about now is Cuts in spending so
we're not talking about let's just give
loads of extra money to people who
actually need it in fact of course there
is already a process through which this
is happening but the question now for
Jeremy Hunter which is sunak is where
can they find some cuts and the worries
that everybody has been having is our
benefit is going to be increasing in
line with inflation which of course they
should and of course pensions were made
were mentioned the triple lock is
probably going to be maintained for this
year because I'm suspecting the quite a
lot of pensioners or the ones that the
conservatives are thinking about vote
Tory well I want to come back to the
issue of pitch in a moment but I think
we're still
tackling this question of somebody is
going to have to take some pain here in
fact from Jeremy Hunt he says everyone's
going to have to take some pain and the
question is
who takes the most
Joe Grady how do you make the
distinction between
who needs to be protected and who
doesn't well I think just on the
question of the means test before I get
to that because my answer to that will
be no means testing is dehumanizing
right and we know we know for decades
why various governments have tried to
remove means testing
what I would say in answer to your
question is
flip this conversation why are we
focusing on some of the most vulnerable
people in society and asking how we can
make their lives that little bit more
uncomfortable you know and in the UK If
we look at the minute nurses or our
members in in higher education and
further education people who are working
really important jobs for society
um helping people improve their lives
for education and when they get paid at
the end of the month they might spend
two days with money in their bank
account before they go into their
overdraft again so there are people who
are in financial Dire Straits who are
doing everything that is after them as
Citizens and I'll just end on this why
aren't we asking should we be taxing
CEOs more why aren't we asking why
shareholders get so much profit that's
the real question we need to be debating
you do you agree with that our audiences
um I think responding really positively
to that point of view I mean absolutely
I mean we've seen over the last few
months it's those that are worst off
that have been impacted the most and
their lives they're the one are taking
on the most burden I think as it is I
think and i would support
um a wealth tax and it was said only
last year that a one one percent tax on
households with over a million pounds
could generate I think it was 260
billion pounds that could be reinvested
back into our public sector for example
and that could help run our NHS for a
year minimum okay all right well look
we're going to come back to this
question of who really is wealthy in a
moment I want to talk to uh Scott
stripping in Devon who I think has a
slightly different point of view on this
question of where the money should come
from Scott good evening what's your view
of this issue
well listen
we're all finding it hard at the minute
but I I do think people can help
themselves a little bit more
um I I we we've all had to
um cut out some subscriptions you know
whether that's Netflix Disney plus I've
canceled Experian ancestry that kind of
thing so I do I do think there's a
little bit more people can be doing at
home to help themselves as opposed to
just uh pointing the finger at uh
wanting more help
uh so Scott I'm hoping you're not
recommending that anybody stops their
Sky subscription but um what do you how
do you respond to uh what Joe has said
that this is
either way the wrong way round that what
we should be really thinking about are
the people who are more affluent already
well I I think you need to look more at
how much is given already uh how much
more you want to give I mean I think
people forget that we're coming out of
covid and billions of spent to keep
people at home and uh to keep a roof
over their head but
um I mean how much money does the
government have I mean Jeremy Hunt has
said that uh we're running out of money
we haven't got enough and we all need to
pay more so um you know where's the
money going to come from okay thank you
uh
Joe Grady I mean there is an issue here
I mean
It's relatively easy to say let's tax
the high earners but we know that
actually that raises relatively small
sums and it whether you think that
Jeremy Hunt has to find 30 billion or 60
billion taxing people who earn more than
let's say 150 000 a bit more isn't going
to fill that hole
I think we need to take a step back
right we've just heard of VT at the
beginning of this about the nation's
credit card this government set the
economy on fire with a mini budget and I
doubt if we're talking in this language
we'd get a loan from wonger now right as
the UK and yet we're being asked by
these people to accept that you know a
college lecturer who earns 25 000 pounds
a year just needs to cancel a Netflix
subscription it is absurd there has to
be a bigger structural change and for
working people they can see that for
decades their wages have been shrinking
my members get paid 25 less now than
they did in 2009 the answer is not more
of the medicine that they've been giving
us for three decades okay
Andrew Huff you asked this question
about means testing it's not um a very
popular solution uh down here and indeed
across the panel what what is your
response to what Joe Grady's just said
I agree with them that basically at the
end of the day it should be the Richer
people paying for it if you just look at
our past prime ministers Johnson was is
worth 1.6 million net Hunters 1.8
million net sunac is 750 million net
so basically turkeys will not vote for
Christmas
okay and these are the people who can
afford it
okay okay Vicky uh are we being a bit
unrealistic here about this the the
possibility of raising the vast sums
even if there are cuts which we'll come
to a little later they're still going to
be the story is at the moment 20 billion
are there about that needs to come out
of tax that's going to have to come from
a lot of people rather than a few rich
people isn't it well absolutely and of
course I don't think they'll be able to
raise income tax but there is such
amount of money that can be raised and
is being raised and has been raised for
some time now but just keeping the the
allowances the tax allowances Frozen so
what's going on right now is because of
high inflation yes wages are not keeping
up with inflation but they're still
rising and Rising much more than they
have done for a very long period of time
on an annual basis you collect a lot
more tax if you just leave the
allowances where they are loads more
people are now entering the for the
first time paying tax which they didn't
do before and many more millions are
beginning to pay and will increasingly
do so because this allowances May well
be frozen for the next four years it
possibly even longer the the millions
will start paying the higher rate of
income tax so there is a way of making
everyone pay through the back door and
and this isn't really discussed enough
and people don't quite realize that
that's what's going on well we are
actually going to be talking about how
the the uh that pain can be spread more
or will need to be spread a bit more
widely in a moment you're watching the
great debate up next is it fair to
protect pensioners incomes at the
expense of working people who are
struggling right now
pensions will be going up by 10 linked
to inflation do nurses have broader
shoulders than your wealthy retiree
spending time in the golf course
it was in our Manifesto to keep the the
triple lock our machine was also very
clear that he's a prime minister that's
standing on that 2019 Manifesto when
winter comes
I can't tell you
oh I'm going to do it but
I like to
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
to
your weeknight on Sky News I'm in the
man Rasheed and I'm Skies north of
England correspondent
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and Global impact
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking who should bear the brunt
of the Autumn budget
now wherever the ax Falls this week it
seems likely that the pension triple
lock will be protected older people are
important to any government more of them
tend to vote more of us tend to vote but
there are questions over how long the
state can go on spending more on the
affluent old when many younger working
people are still struggling to get on
the housing ladder and to make ends meet
let me see what the sentiment on our
wall is at the beginning of this part
might come back to you at the end of the
part
um question for our viewers panel is
this
is it time for the government to drop
their commitment to the triple lock
let's see who thinks that Jeremy Hunt
should say
we have regrettably had to
decide that we can't commit to the
triple lock and let me remind you a 10
increase in pensions for people like
Phillips
well thank you all very much virtually
our whole viewers panel think that I
should get a 10
uplift in my state pension Vicky does
that seem just to you
well of course we have to bear in mind
that the state pension isn't that great
so by comparison to what people get in
other countries it's pretty low in
relation to average earnings so you get
less pension than people who are just
beginning to work and have an allowance
of twelve and a half thousand pounds or
twelve thousand five hundred and seventy
so the pension that you get is less than
that so uh for the average person and
most people don't have an occupational
pension scheme so we're talking about
the year as a whole so of course there
are people with occupational business
schemes who get a lot more but the
average pensioner is by no means
particularly rich and if you look at all
the extra costs that they now have to
bear whether it's food whether it's
keeping themselves warm whether it is
even you know going around and looking
after their grandchildren for example
which many of them do what do you want
is you want an active older population
that goes out and spends money and keeps
the economy going all right Vicky um
let's talk to somebody who might is
objectively on maybe on the other side
of this and he may agree with you we'll
see uh I'm going to talk to Alex Hicks
who um is a young person Alex you're
um well by my light you're a very young
person but what do you think about this
about this point
so I'm 21 years old I've just graduated
University I've got 50 000 pounds worth
of debt and living in a shared flight in
London
um and essentially me and my friends are
faced with the prospect of you know not
being able to get on a property ladder
you know because of crazy property
prices and more and high mortgage rates
and the economic prospects for my
generation the medium time also look at
uncertain at best
um so it's becoming clear that the
likelihood that I'll ever own a home is
Slim so my question is is I understand
that we're going through difficult times
but why should pensioners be given
special treatment with my generation
footing the bill you know especially
given the state of Public Services you
know nurses are looking at far less than
a 10
um pay okay so yeah okay Alex um
you'll I think you may be in the
minority amongst our audience but but
it's a good question for our panel uh is
it fair to prioritize protecting
pensions cuejo you and Alex between you
are still if you added up your ages
you're still young than a pension age
yes what what do you think of what he
said do you know what I hear Alexander
hear his concerns especially about um
student loans and the cost that young
people have especially coming out of a
university and it is a conversation that
needs to
um happen but in regards to pensions I
think obviously we know the triple up
was introduced in 2010 it was a
Manifesto promise in 2019 and I think
it's something that needs to be
um kept and fulfilled by the government
having said that it's not an excuse for
the government not to look after those
that are worst off within British
Society those doing the worst that I
think they need to find a solution to
keep the triple lock but also make sure
they're looking after those um that are
are worst off
clear
what is the solution if there is one
well the mathematical solution is that
the triple lock I'm afraid is doomed
because of the demographics within our
population if we're going to keep paying
out an inflation link benefit to the
growing number of pensioners in our
society as Vicki said some of whom who
were relying solely on that money the
majority but others who have got pension
wealth others who maybe are still
working then you've got to increase the
number of people who are paying tax in
the workforce to sustain that population
now a big debate that's going on at the
moment is the falling birth rate in
Britain how do we increase our
population to support this elderly
demographic do we encourage people to
have children well the cost of child
care is yet another thing that is really
really holding back the lives of of
young people in their 30s and Beyond who
are trying to start a family or do we
allow more immigrant immigration to come
in which is obviously another really hot
issue especially for the conservative
party after brexit so very difficult
question I want to follow up this point
that both you and Vicky have made
essentially about the poor pensioners I
think um in the next period the number
of over 85s is going to double and a lot
of those will be poor let's talk to
Eddie Baines
um who who is indeed a pensioner and I
think Eddie you're in Lancashire is that
right
if Eddie can hear me
um
can you hear me Eddie I can hear you now
yes thank you great I was just saying
that we've been having a discussion here
about
pensioner poverty talk to us about your
situation
my only income is the state pension I
have a very small pension part that
um isn't going to last forever it's my
view that those in work as I did need to
pay more tax especially especially the
very wealthy uh and is it fair and
reasonable that the government not carry
out their election Manifesto promise on
the triple lock uh not once but maybe
twice
okay so Eddie you're for the maintenance
of the triple lock as it is let's talk
to um another another pensioner Andrew
Snowden who um I think may not be quite
social Andrew what's your view about
this
well I think we're being given false uh
um
there is really no shortage of cash it's
how it's distributed uh it's like being
told you know should I shoot my wife or
my daughter you just don't shoot either
you know of those of a million pound
plus
um they pay 11 tax or sorry they pay
under 30 tax and some of them pay less
than 11 tax a a wealth tax of one
percent would produce 260 billion
according to
um according to mlc report a year or two
ago so it is about redistribution and
you shouldn't be then attacking people
who are really at or below the poverty
line
um as Vicky has said we we already have
one of the lowest
um safety nets and pensioners of course
will get uh
taxed if they have other income if
they're above 12 000 so that many people
are taxed who have secondary incomes so
this is a um this is a threshold but
people have worked all their life for
um I'm wealthy I have low income the
threshold should the thresholds be uh
set for everybody and that includes
pensions okay Andrew
part of you that says well actually
there are well-off pensioners who really
don't need this uplift and if we didn't
give it to them and we could support
those who really do the Hallmark of a
good Society is not how we treat them as
wealthy it's how we treat our most
vulnerable and the question at hand now
the point is this would help you but
without creating any incredibly complex
situation we are debating whether or not
pensioners of you know who all of whom
have worked all their lives paid taxes
should get what has been promised to
them rather than have to Forfeit it
because the government have botched up
the economy so I don't think we should
get into should we do this for them the
lock should stay but I'll also say you
know it shouldn't be do we punish young
people starting out in Life or are we
just saddle with debt or do we punish
old people where the fifth richest
economy in the world all right let's see
if there has been any point to this
discussion At All by going back to our
viewers panel and asking you same
question I asked you at the beginning of
this part
um in fact let me ask it this way does
any of you think that Mr Hunt should
stand up on Thursday and say regrettably
we have decided that we cannot sustain
the triple lock anybody been convinced
that that should be a Thing Worth doing
okay I can see one two
uh maybe three four five uh
well okay well I suspect McDonald's not
going to do that and he certainly won't
be doing it uh if if this is
representative of the electric
electorate thank you very much you are
watching the great debate still to come
what's the fairest way to prioritize our
public services and who's really running
the country the government or the market
ambulance response times across all
categories are the worst on record Our
Midwives and our maternity support
workers are facing real financial
hardship and no one is listening
nurses have voted to take strike action
five potential strikes already a real
nightmare for the chancellor and the
prime minister
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking who should bear the brunt
of the Autumn budget
one of Jeremy Hunt's main tasks
following the chaos that followed quasi
quateng's mini budget is setting out a
credible plan for government spending
and Taxation one that will keep the
financial markets happy
and it's prompted some to ask do the
markets now run the country here's our
economics and data editor Ed Conway
may only now be entering recession but
the economic crisis has already claimed
some victims
Rusty was on the brink of buying a
property at the very moment interest
rates spiked after the many budget in
three days his mortgage offer went up by
400 pounds a month 5 000 pounds a year
it was a massive change and a shock at
first and I'll be honest I had to decide
do I want to change my standard of
living what do I want to give up for
this property it could be 1500 pounds
tomorrow right so it was a bit it was a
bit of a risk it is a reminder that the
events of recent months were not just
numbers on a screen they had real
consequences but as the new Chancellor
puts the finishing touches to the Autumn
statement this week questions still
remain about what really happened was
the government really all to blame some
are asking wasn't someone else
responsible here what about the bank of
England weren't they too slow to raise
interest rates wasn't the Fatal moment
for Liz truss when Andrew Bailey
withdrew his support for the bond market
if so that would make this the key
intervention you've got three days left
now you've got to get this done when he
appeared at an event in Washington and
imposed that deadline
three days later the chancellor was gone
shortly followed by the PM leading some
to argue that the governor really sealed
her fate still standing in an interview
with Sky News he dismissed that
speculation I vehemently disagree with
this because it is based on fallacy had
we gone on with that intervention beyond
the point of financial stability being
suitably restored we'd have been
creating another problem which is the
you know what economists tend to call a
moral asset Hazard problem I.E you know
people who said all the banking was
always going to intervene and that's
wrong we did the job we set out to do
you didn't opposal is trust no of course
we didn't just proposal this trust I
would never do anything like that and
most protagonists argue that the former
PM made her own mistakes including one
Economist who said he warned her we said
markets are in the very febrile state if
your policy actions are not clear and
not understood there will be a market
crisis so you you warned very explicitly
about this risk I said this publicly and
privately
and with the era of cheap money coming
to an end others fear that this British
crisis might be a sign of further crises
to come the eventual story might feel
very different to the one we're hearing
today Ed Conway Sky News
at Conway writes let's go to Yuan
Carmichael in Kilmarnock on this issue
of spending Services cuts and all of
that Ewan what's your thought
yeah
hi yeah I I think it's really important
um that you know things like spending
cuts on austerity are really dangerous
um no government Department should
really have to cut corners or lay off
staff to save money
um and departments such as education you
know it's a really a struggle
um for for particularly for Education
staff and also defense and our support
against Ukraine and obviously Health as
well with with the ongoing crisis that
we're facing so we should absolutely not
return to austerity
um not only it's a very good idea and it
can cost money and lives but also
because it will leave a financial burden
for young people like myself to pick up
in many decades to come as well
Ewan thank you very much and indeed
um stick there for a second uh Joe Grady
um are you and you know the sort of
person that your members are teaching
and his point that we shouldn't go back
to austerity everybody I would want to
be in that situation but do we actually
have an option now
yes it's a very simple answer and I'll
go back to something I said you know uh
earlier in the show
when we are told by people there is no
option other than austerity we need to
look at who those people are because
they're usually the people who've been
saying there's no option to austerity
for several years now if not a decade or
longer and those people are saying we
need more of this to get through this
and all we see is Wages continuing to
get lower at the minute inflation
getting higher more children getting
hungry more pensioners not cooking hot
meals more of this is not the solution
and I I couldn't be clear about it okay
so what is I think that there's so many
more progressive taxation uh mechanisms
that have already been discussed on this
show
um I would also like to draw attention
to you know much of the money that we
saw going on what seemed to be dodgy
contracts during the pandemic nice tax
cuts for friends Lord knows what happens
to a lot of money during the bonfire of
the mini budget I want to put a lens on
where that money is going and the type
of money we could raise through proper
taxation Vicky
um there's slack in the system there are
people who are sort of uh apparently uh
swelling with cash and we could get it
off them
well I think there are some intentions
to do precisely that and the first thing
that happened of course when the mini
budget proved to be such a disaster is
that the top rate of income tax that had
been slashed or you know thrown out of
the window really the 45p was reinstated
so that was the first sign that that the
the whole tone of the mini budget was
wrong because it was immediately labeled
as the budget or the mini budget for the
rich so that at least is gone and there
are no discussions of even reducing the
threshold from where you start paying
that higher rate of income tax so I
think there's been a complete reversal
of thinking in that area and there is
more that can come capital gains tax can
be looked at again and I think there are
some ideas too there about what to do
with this threshold so dividend tax
um increases are quite likely to happen
as well so there are all sorts of leaks
that suggest that it is widening the
sort of tax you know area that that
they're going to be looking at is
widening but nevertheless you still
don't raise huge amount out of those
areas I want to come to one particular
tax inheritance tax a little later but
Claire Barrett
you deal with people spending individual
consumer retail spending so
this is going to mean something
significant for the average person the
just about managing
person that we spoke to right at the top
of the show
have we are we sort of missing the point
here that actually the bulk of this of
what needs to happen now is going to
affect that great middle swathe of
households absolutely and unfortunately
the acceleration in mortgage interest
rates which we were just hearing about
there from Rusty that happened after the
mini budget has really pushed the cost
of living crisis up the income scale
you've got people whose happiness
basically depends on at what point their
fixed rate mortgage comes to an end you
could have colleagues in an office who
have identical jobs identical salaries
and by luck one of them has done a
five-year fix and the other did a
two-year and all of a sudden their
monthly costs are going to increase by
hundreds and and hundreds of pounds it
is a real disaster that this has
happened so quickly we knew that the
economy was turning around that interest
rates were rising up again it's not
taking as as quickly as we would like
for them to stabilize although the bank
of England thinks that interest rates
are not going to be as high as the
financial markets are predicting so
there's a bit of a standoff they'd be
over six percent the bank of England is
now saying what four four and a half
that sort of foreign
in the long term but I think the thing
that is slightly missing from this
debate is like why was we're so aware of
what the cost of living crisis means for
our own personal finances we're not as
aware of how bad things have got for the
government's own finances and for me on
Thursday seeing what the office for
Budget budget responsibility is actually
saying when it comes to the numbers on
debt now that was what was missing at
the mini budget we didn't have the
numbers we're going to get them this
time and they're going to be really
horrible and that's why we're being
warmed up for big tax okay let's go back
because um I want to talk to Martin
Travis who I could see very animated in
the earlier earlier part of our
discussion about pensions and I think
Martin you've got a a point to make
about this whole issue of how we Square
the circle Martin
yeah thank you good evening Trevor I
really don't think that we should be
prioritizing uh the triple lock it's not
where the conversation needs to be at
we've just seen uh rail strikes on go
under and we're up to the NHS or walkout
and this really is not where the
conversation should be we should be
concentrating on the nurses and the
workers to actually look after them
really and the triple lock usually
parked as a priority for this government
really
okay
Joe greatly I mean
he's making a point here because you're
telling me that your members need help
they need a pay rise and so on and
they're in big trouble and he's making
the point there's a way to deal with
that in reality why are you so resistant
to to making that sum add up well I'm
not I mean if you look at our members
because you know you've raised it so in
in the UK at the minute we're about to
launch on a nationwide strike action in
universities if we look at what's
happening in universities the people
that run universities earn 44.5 million
amongst them we're talking about the top
people the vice chancellors but the
sector has 40 billion pounds of reserves
and the people who work in it have had a
25 pay cut students have had fees
trebled along with everything else there
is money to pay people properly people
are voting to take strike action not
because they think pensioners are
getting it because they're saying enough
is enough and the money is there all
right let's go to a break the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt says he will be fair and
compassionate but morale in many
workplaces is at rock bottom if we want
growth how important is happiness in the
workforce there are two reasons why
candy isn't working her left knee and
her right knee she wants to get back to
work in nursing but she's temporarily on
Universal Credit levels of economic
inactivity among the long-term sick have
risen by more than half a million since
the pandemic
more and more people are finding
themselves in vulnerable positions
whether it's personally or the impact
that the economic climate is having on
their businesses
[Applause]
[Music]
I discovered that there's a quite a big
backstory to the creation of the SAS
particularly a character called Dudley
Clarke
um and so when I researched the book I
took it right back to the beginning of
the war and this guy basically invented
modern Special Forces what we know as
the SES Commandos he invented the U.S
Rangers he inspired the creation of OSS
which became the CIA and I knew none of
that even though I'd served in the
military Clark was a 40 year old staff
officer being in the war and he um he
hated the idea of the second world war
he was dismayed by it because his uh he
lost a lot of friends in the first world
war and he thought that the way to win
the second world will be something
called subliminal methods so he thought
by Special Forces little pinprick raids
behind the lines and deception of the
enemy we could defeat the much bigger
German Army and that and he started
doing that well before the narrative we
know which is David Sterling came along
in 1941 he was at actually up and
running before he got commissioned to
create the SAS the big successes he had
was creating modern Special Forces which
started with the Commandos which then
developed into the lrdg which the Royal
long-range desert grew which is a unit
that operated in the desert which then
led to the creation of the SAS basically
and in all of that he did he did things
like he um he deceived Rommel I mean
there was a famous attack in North
Africa where Roman was on holiday with
his wife in Italy when the British
attacked for his birthday in a hotel and
he and he did that Sicily he he diverted
uh forces away from Sicily Italy at the
anzio beachhead
um British forces waited ashore
unopposed because the Germans were
further north thinking they were going
to attack there and then in 1944 he
diverted all all of the Mediterranean
forces down to the South by creating a
fake Army that we thought that the
Germans thought was going to attack up
through Croatia and Greece we went
straight from the second world war into
the Cold War so we wanted to use these
skills against the Russians
um and so Snippets of the stories have
come out you'll have heard of things
like operation mincemeat which is part
of a bigger deception you did
um there was a there was I was Monty's
double so he he came up with that idea
of creating getting an actor to play
Monty and wander around Mediterranean so
little pieces came out but the overall
picture the overall story was kept under
wraps and actually the last of his um
last of his missions was only
Declassified in 2000 so quite recently
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking who should bear the brunt
of the Autumn budget
now since the covered pandemic the
workforce has changed many people have
left their jobs all together others are
choosing the path of quiet quitting
that's the idea of doing the bare
minimum to avoid getting sacked but the
UK's growth and productivity is still
sluggish inflation is it a 40-year high
with a threat of a long recession
looming
so against this Gloomy backdrop what can
we do to lift the mood in the workplace
right now
uh Jackie Mahoney Jackie I think you've
got a question for our panel on this on
this point
yeah I mean I work in um social care so
um
there are lots of things that could be
um created within the workforce
environment
particularly pay is a particular issue
and being recognized in terms of the
level of paid certainly with social care
Workforce then that is that is something
that is a real issue in terms of
Recruitment and Retention are you
recognizing terms of qualification in
terms of training and investment
environments so so your question for our
panel is Jackie
how can we create a happier Workforce
okay well let's look at let's get
optimistic thank you Jackie your
question is how do we create a happy
Workforce
um now question yeah the nation is
waiting yeah you have the answer
um yeah um and I think it is to the
basic answer that I think everyone's
been fighting for and that's to pay our
public sector workers what it is they
deserve I mean we've heard last week
that nurses are going to go out on
strike and we remember what the NHS gave
to us during the pandemic they were
breaking their backs to save lives and
we were out banging pots in Celebration
by the end of the day that wasn't paying
their bills that wasn't feeding their
kids what they want is to be able to pay
their bills feed their kids at the end
of the month and live a decent
um have a decent standard of living
unfortunately they're not getting that
and we saw last week an article where a
nurse is having to eat the leftovers of
um their patients or you look at
education for example and teachers and
staff are having to open food banks not
just for the students not just for for
their parents but the staff there and
we're seeing the same in the NHS we need
to prioritize them they are the backbone
to this country and that's where the
foundation starts I think all right well
stay hold on for that second I think
we've got um
and we've got a student teacher are you
Dan Dan Aitkin I think we've got a
student teacher who I think might
respond to exactly to that point Dan
what's your
what's your feeling you're you're going
to be a teacher is that right
yeah yeah I'm going to the teacher now
I'm starting next year and right now I
have little to no incentive to actually
pursue the career because I've it's
clear that I'm not going to have the
money to survive after a couple of years
there's
um the pay progression levels out very
very quickly and the support for
students the student teachers and for
myself is going to be abysmal
um and if it's not enough funding in I
don't see how school's gonna stay open
it's that then on being on the side is
bad Dan you're painting a pretty
miserable prospectus there why are you
why are you doing it why are you
it's something that I've always had a
passion for but there's
what it helps that I have the emotional
reward of it but that doesn't pay my
bills okay Claire Barrett
you study workplaces you write about
them what do people need aside from
money they need for their vocations not
to be exploited Trevor which is what
sadly we are seeing in the teaching
profession I come from a family of
teachers the nursing profession some
members of my family or nurses one of
the retired nurse and also as Jackie
said at the beginning of the segment the
caring profession now time and time
again even you know people who work with
nurseries work with little children
there are huge problems with the nursery
funding
um at the moment care is just not
something we value in a society it's
something that women have traditionally
done for free that is probably the
reason why and we really need to see the
value of it as Society changes and ages
Joe very quickly not specifically about
your members but what could Jeremy Hunt
do that would maybe make the tough
period coming
more palatable for people in workplaces
workplaces that that's their morale that
makes them not enjoy being there is
overwork
the government could introduce trialing
a four-day working week that would be
great that could make people a lot
happier
that's good now the answer
for two by twenty percent but it's
serious overworked you know is is really
what pushes people out is what the
teachers just saying Vicky you think
that's worth trying well of course if
you get paid full time but working for
four days a week then that's pretty good
but but in reality flexibility has
proved to improve productivity rather
than reduce it
all right look we could talk about this
all night but that in fact is all we
have time for this evening and it
remains for me to say thank you to our
panelists here in the studio Vicky price
Claire Barrett
quejo twinabella and Joe Grady
of course as always it's you at home or
at the center of our conversation and if
you'd like to be part of the program
next time get in touch email us at the
great debate at Sky dot UK
and of course I want to say thank you to
our viewers panel always contribution
lifting our debate and thank you at home
for joining us uh we you keep talking
and we'll see you again at the same time
next week for the great debate
[Music]
[Applause]